hi there today we'll look at super masks
in superposition by mitchell wurzman
vivek ramanujan at al so on a high level
this paper tackles
the problem of sequentially learning
many many tasks without catastrophic
forgetting
by leveraging these things called super
masks a super mask is basically a
binary mask that you want lays over a
randomly initialized neural network to
make
the mask network perform better than a
random initialization
they will train these masks for each of
the tasks that they consider
and then at inference time they can
recover the
task that the data is from and therefore
kind of do this lifelong multi-task
learning better than the baselines that
they compare against in fact
they can do better without knowing the
task than the baselines can
with knowing the task so that's pretty
pretty cool
i this is a pretty dense paper in terms
of content
and we won't go over everything in the
paper but
i will go over the ideas and what
kind of what i think makes them work so
yeah stick around if you want to know
that also
consider sharing this video out tell
your friends about it
and subscribe if you haven't it's uh it
helps so
yeah cool so let's dive in
we present the super masks in
superposition model
capable of sequentially learning
thousands of tasks without catastrophic
forgetting
so the term catastrophic forgetting
comes from the
world of this kind of sequential
multi-task learning
where you have a model let's call say
this is your model the black box
and you let it learn on a tasks let's
say this is an image recognition task so
you have a data set
and you let it run on this data set you
learn the data set maybe it's c410
right so this is c410 cool
and now the model can do c410 pretty
well
then you also want to learn a different
task you want to learn
mnist okay so you have mnist and you
want to learn
mnist and you want to learn that one so
your hope is that your final model can
do both
so you'll take this one and you simply
train it on
mnist as well and then you know we know
there's this kind of fine tuning
pre-training and so on so your hope
would be
that at the end it can do both but then
you want another one you want imagenet
okay now imagenet is a pretty big data
set so you take your model and you also
train it on
imagenet and with time the model is
always going to be very good at the task
you just learned
but it is going to forget the tasks that
you learned previously this is the
catastrophing forgetting problem you
might ask why don't i just train on all
the tasks
equally like at the same time and that's
a valid question you can do that but
um this in the task description here
it's necessary that we learn the task
one after another because
you know maybe we get this data in this
year and then
it's pretty big data we can't just
afford to retrain on all the data all
the time
we want to kind of continuously
integrate our knowledge this is very
important in
the fields of like lifelong learning
where
you want to kind of the the hope is you
can build a system that continuously
integrates experience
but doesn't forget the old experience
okay
and the experience might come from new
data sets and so on
but you don't want to forget the old
ones so catastrophic forgetting is one
of the main problems in these types of
research in this field of research of
lifelong learning
and this paper is going to tackle this
how it's sort of so if you think of what
could you do
right here what you could do is you
could simply not use the same model
right you can simply train the
different models for each task and just
keep them around
right and at you know test time you need
some way of deciding
um so there are two different scenarios
in at test time so you learn all of
these models and then at test time
there's an image and it could be that i
tell you that this image by the way
that's an mnist image
right so you just grab this model and
you apply it very cool
um or it could be that i don't tell you
what image it is like
you have no clue then you need a way to
decide
where it comes from but once you do
decide where it comes from
it's again pretty easy once you think i
think this is an mnist
thing you can apply this one so you
could technically do that
but it's very unhelpful because these
models
they can be large right first of all
they can be large
so um that means
it costs you to store those and second
of all
there might actually be some overlap
like c410 and imagenet are both natural
images so they might
benefit from each other's feature in
some
way now what we're going to do here is
we're
sort of going to do this separate models
approach
namely we're going to use these we're
going to build these
super masks so super masks are the
second
thing that we're going to combine here
our approach uses a randomly initialized
fixed base network and for each task
find a sub network a super mask that
achieves
good performance so what's a super mask
a super mask comes from these kind of
papers about lottery ticket hypothesis
and one of these papers uh
discovered basically or conjectured and
then showed
in evidence that if you have a network
that is
randomly initialized just like this is
your neural network the gray
thing and there is a way
to mask it which means masking basically
means that you
either activate or inactivate
connections so
you have your network and you simply
multiply it by a
binary mask that for each connection is
a one or a zero
so like one so here is like zero zero
zero zero
zero this is a one this is a zero zero
zero this is a 1.
so the network isn't going to be zeros
and ones but
it's going to be multiplied each
connection is going to be multiplied by
a 0 or a 1
which means wherever there's a 1
whatever
weight that connection had that will be
the value of
the weight of the connection if is it a
zero
whatever weight that connection had it
will be
it will be pinned to zero so there will
be no signal flowing
so this paper established that
if you take a randomly initialized
neural network there is a way
to mask it and you can find those masks
where
if you mask in a particular way the
network will already perform better than
random
on a given task so there is a way to
solve mnist by using a randomly
initialized neural network and then
simply masking it cleverly
and then the mask network will have a
good accuracy
on mnist okay and they've they found
that and i have i've made a video
about that and um the
sort of intuition behind the super masks
is
um this is just my intuition is that
you know mnist i'm this is what i'm
guessing
mnist is a relatively easy task in fact
most of the tasks they're considering in
these papers
are relatively easy and
if you have a randomly initialized
neural network basically what you have
around is a bunch of weight right so if
if i have my two layers right here
and then each connection here is is a
number like
0.25 this is you know seven
this is negative three and so on now
they're going to consider
they here are going to consider um
weights that are
initialized in a very special way but
ultimately you just have a bunch of
random weights lying around
and if the task is super easy let's say
and the
the neural network is sufficiently over
parameterized
there might be many many ways of
achieving your goal
so rather than being able to adjust the
weights
like you would do when you train the
neural network you would actually change
those numbers
you get away with simply selecting the
combination of weights that will you
know give you a good performance
so in it's kind of it's sort of a mix of
uh dropout and and vector quantization
so in vector quantization you also you
get away with quantizing the vectors
to given uh precision and here
the task is easy enough such that by
simple over parameterization
and selecting of the weights that you
have around mixing them correctly
by simply so you can't mix arbitrarily
but you can mix with zero or one
you get good enough okay so this is
sort of my hypothesis my hypothesis
would be that the harder the task
the the harder it gets to find super
masks that perform
well that's what i think is going but
never
less to say for the tasks they're
considering here you can
find these super masks and there is a
way to do that um
by using gradient descent even though
the super masks are discrete
so what we're going to do is we're going
to use
the same randomly initialized neural
network for
each of the tasks right so this is like
c410
this is mnist this is imagenet we're
going to use the same gray network
but we're going to find an individual
mask for each of those
networks for each of those tasks on top
of the same network
and they're all going to perform
relatively well according to the super
mask conjecture
now again this is not surprising
and the fact that we always use the same
randomly initialized
network you know isn't really it's not
really necessary that we always use the
same but in this case they say okay
we always use the same and then we only
need to
store the mask for each task the mask is
much simpler than the
weights because you know a 32-bit
floating point number is 32 bits while a
masking bit is only one bit so we save
basically a factor of
32 in our models but essentially
essentially right it's not the case
that we are training the same model
and some continue learning it's much
more akin
to training a sing a
training one model per task um
and then inferring the task just
that we do it in a much more crude way
so it's more like learning a compressed
model per task i
i find uh it's a better way to look at
it than
than continuous learning in any case you
learn these super
masks and then here is the the the hard
bit okay the easy bit
is if i tell you which tasks the
inference data point the test data point
comes from
you have a pretty easy time um
classifying it you simply select the
mask accordingly
you run forward pass and that's it if i
don't tell you where the test data point
comes from that's the hard part
now they need a way to decide
where the data point comes from
and the the idea that they have right
here
they have sort of multiple ideas but the
main idea the first idea is that um if
you have trained
these individual models for the
individual tasks
then okay there is not
good explanation here
then the correct model should be very
confident
right this is an assumption that you
make so i'm going to
take my image of the test set and i'm
going to feed it
through the model one which you know you
have to
separate this idea is separate from the
masks
at its core it's simply saying if i have
three different models that i've trained
for three different tasks and now i get
an input i don't know which one
it's from i can simply feed it to each
one of them
and i can look at the output
distribution so maybe
my output input distribution right here
this is
as you can see three output neurons it's
a three class classifier right here
my output distribution is somewhat here
like this
and here it's like this
and here it's like i
shouldn't do that i got a comment you
know who you are
and here it's like this
okay so which one would you pick and
their
answer here is we should pick this one
because of it has very low entropy
so this middle model here is very very
sure about this data point it's very
sure about its prediction
because it the distance basically of the
top prediction to all the other
predictions is so
high it's very confident in its
prediction whereas
here you can see that the distance is
not too high also here the distance
between the highest and the
others is not too high so they say
we are going to pick the model or the
mask
in this case for which the output
entropy
is the highest and that is
a heuristic for now but it tends to work
pretty well
um it has a bit to do with how the
relatively difficult your tasks are so
your tasks need to be kind of equally
difficult um otherwise
it's not otherwise this can get a little
bit
um a little bit out of hand but there
are ways to solve it and they allude to
that in the kind of future
work section but in this case if the
tasks are
equally hard and they consider tasks
that are equally hard
then the entropy is a good measure of
how confident these things are
and therefore we can check which task it
is by
using the entropy as a heuristic all
right
so we're left with simply trying each of
the masks and then decide taking the one
that has the highest entropy
now they say this is costly because if
we've learned you know a thousand tasks
uh we need to try each of the thousand
masks
in order to do that so they go for
something else
and this is the second word in the title
this superposition
word so instead
of doing that what they'll do is they'll
use a superposition of masks and
actually the picture also i find more
descriptive
than the formula i can write down the
formula down here
so what they'll do is they'll say why
don't we just
overlap all of the masks so we'll have
all of these masks
m i for one for each tasks and we'll
initialize them with coefficients alpha
i will just
mix them like this and
alpha here it's initialized in one over
k where k is the number of tasks okay
we'll just mix them
and then we'll multiply them by the
weights of the neural network
and that's will that neural network
is where we input our image into
okay so what does that give us
that basically gives us a mix of all
the networks like it's it's pretty safe
to say that the entire network is going
to be
in there and maybe sometimes you know
multiple times like if multiple masks
use the same weight it's going to be
in their there with a higher weight and
so on
so that's what you see right here you
can see that all the masks are
overlapped in superposition
with each other now what does the output
give you the output gives you nothing
the output gives you kind of the average
prediction of the network so this here
is going to give you
kind of the sort of the average
prediction of all of the networks which
isn't very helpful
but of course what we can do
is we can look at the gradients of this
so if we from this calculate
the entropy which is here denoted h
and we calculate we back propagate
this so we back propagate this to the
alphas
and we calculate the gradient of the
entropy
with respect to each of the alphas
what does that give us so what's the
intuition here the intuition
is if i change my alpha a bit
how does the entropy change so basically
this gives you the
sensitivity of the entropy to these
alpha parameters
so if this is high what does it mean it
means that
this mask right here has a big influence
on the entropy
specifically if i were to increase the
alpha
then the entropy would
increase okay and if i were to decrease
the alpha then the entropy
would decrease that's the the kind of
what what the gradient gives you
now did i say before we want the one
with the highest
entropy i'm pretty sure we want the one
with the
with the lowest entropy like we want the
one where we're
very very very sure right i i might have
said that
absolutely wrong so
if you see right here this is the
formalism
first we associate each of the k learned
super masks with a coefficient alpha
initially set to 1 over k
each alpha can be interpreted as the
belief that super mask
m is the correct mask equivalently the
belief that the current unknown task is
task i the model output is then computed
with a weighted superposition of
all learned tasks which is this thing
right here
the correct mask should produce a
confidence low
entropy output therefore we recover the
correct mask
we find the coefficients alpha which
minimize the output entropy
h okay so yes we want the task with the
lowest entropy of course
not with the highest entropy
so if we look at the gradient right here
the gradient basically tells us
how each of the masks will influence the
different
the entropy and if we simply select
the alpha where the gradient here
is the most negative number so we want
this to be as
low as possible not zero but you know
negative
as high as possible then we know that
if we increase this the contribution of
this mask
then the entropy will go down the most
okay and again our hypothesis here is
that
maximum entropy sorry minimum entropy
means most confidence prediction
means that the if all tasks are equally
hard
it probably means that the data point is
from the task where we have the
lowest entropy so
that what's the deal here like they show
in this graph right here they show this
is much faster
so if we if we were to evaluate each
mask individually and measure its
entropy of course with the number of
tasks we'll simply linearly increase our
time
in the forward pass because we need to
try out each of these
masks however if we do
what they're doing here we simply run
one right we mix
these ones we run one forward pass we do
backprop
and they consider two strategies so what
you can do is you can do
gradient descent on these alphas which
takes you know a number of steps to
converge
or you can actually do a single step so
you just observe the gradient
and by the gradient you you recognize
which one has the
lowest gradient and that's the one you
pick so where's the catch here
the catch is that if you do something
like this
[Music]
if you do something is there are two
catches actually
first of all this here is a
a convex combination right this is
convex combination
and the problem isn't convex at all but
if you simply
take this convex combination multiply it
and then look at the gradient
you sort of assume that the problem is a
kind of a convex nicely shaped problem
and if you then observe these
the gradients with respect to the alphas
you you make assumptions
about the problem that might not be true
so you lose you kind of heuristically
approximate the importance of these
masks that's the first thing
the second thing of course is that
it's you still you still are implicitly
saving you're still or implicitly trying
all the models
but you're just not trying them
explicitly you're implicitly trying all
the models because
when you do this combination right here
your auto differentiation library
will actually keep track of what the
individual
models contribute it's just that per
layer so of course this here
this w is multi-layer perceptron
which means that if you have multiple
layers you know there's w1
and there's w2 and
you have your alphas and your alphas are
also
you know you can distribute them into
these sorry your masks are also mask for
layer one mask for layer two and so on
so your auto differentiation package
needs to keep
track of okay mask one goes here with
this
alpha mask two the layer two goes here
with this alpha
and there is
there so it needs to keep track of this
graph it's just that this is highly
optimized and
you also need to you only need to do it
layer by layer
so the contribution
of alpha of mask one
this is maybe alpha i of mask i1 mask
i2 the contribution of the alpha i
will not be explicit in this layer it
will be
implicit um as an average across the
layer
right so again this is you assume in
each layer you assume a convex
combination of all the alphas
and propagate that forward and therefore
if you look at the next layer you can
only view
what mask 2 does mask of layer 2 does as
in terms of a convex combination of
layer one
so you make multiple approximations and
you rely on the optimization of your
auto differentiation library to keep
track
of these different things and do
operations in parallel
and um in in the case where you do it
linearly
i'm going to guess you simply do it as a
sequential operation but it's going to
be exact
so that's the trade-off all right so
we now know how we can figure out where
the
task is from and
let's see how that works so in this
first
task we are looking at split imagenet
split imagenet
simply it takes the imagenet dataset
which is a thousand class dataset
and it distributes it into 100 different
tasks each
is a 10 class classification task now
note
two things first thing is that
split imagenet each task is
approximately as hard
as each other as as the other tasks
right
it's still imagenet classification and
it's
the same number of the of um
it's the same number of labels and
each task is about you know the same
hardness you can make that assumption
and second of all the tasks are actually
pretty pretty easy right
it's hard to distinguish imagenet into a
thousand classes
but if you split that task i'm going to
bet that you have these high resolution
images
and you have a 10 class classification
it's going to be relatively easy so all
our conditions are met for
at least for my hypothesis to hold
and you can see on the right side you
can see split c4
100 which does the same thing to c4 100
it subdivides it into
different very small class
classification tasks
you can see the results the upper bound
here is where you train a single model
for each of the tasks that gets you to
an
average accuracy of 92 percent
so on imagenet 92 percent um
you know it's pretty it's pretty good of
course this is again this is 10 class
which makes the numbers a lot different
with the sub sub so sub sub
you get to this pretty good 88
accuracy this is this super masks in
superposition
this here is a baseline that also does
lifelong learning now
they have these annotations right here
gg
which yes gg haha but so
the first letter will always tell you
whether the task id
is given during training and the second
letter will tell you
whether the task id is given during
testing so
this here simply evaluates whether or
not this masking
is feasible which you can see here it is
so this
will we know which mask to train during
training
and we know which mask to retrieve
during testing so there is nothing of
this entropy
gradients here none of it this simply
evaluates
the viability of the masking approach
which
as you can see it's pretty viable and
it's more viable than
these bass lines
this same thing on the c4
100 right here so you can see they also
evaluate since i guess it's an easier
problem they also evaluate the
number of bytes which they can control
so they can control the number of bytes
in their model
by simply increasing or decreasing the
required sparsity of their mask
so you can change
your mask by saying how sparse you want
it
and of course if you want it more sparse
you get a worse model because
you have less less ones
in your budget to make your model
perform well
but you can see that if they do it with
these
baseline model this batch e you
severely underperform with regard to
the upper bound right here the upper
bound again is where you train a model
per task and separate heads here is
another kind of dummy bass line
where you train a different head for
each of the tasks with a common trunk
that gets you pretty much nowhere
with the sub sub algorithm you do get
almost to the performance of the upper
bound and in fact if you do this
transfer approach right here you do get
there
the transfer approach simply means that
so you do these tasks in succession
right you do task one
okay done you do task two okay done and
for each one you train
a mask okay for each one you train this
is mask one
mask two the transfer approach simply
says
if i start task three i'm going to start
the mask three my initial weights
basically
are going to be a running average of the
masks that i have already considered
or an average there is some amount of
transfer
going on simply
to initialize the weights it's actually
astounding that this helps you
so much but with this if you look at the
actual numbers i believe you even get
like a tiny bit higher
than the uh training a single model for
each of the
tasks okay so
this sort of establishes the viability
of
training the different masks for the
different
tasks which i again i think it is not
surprising because essentially you're
training
a different model per task and
it's just the fact that you do a very
crude model
and that you can store very efficiently
now you might
object and say hey don't i need to store
the underlying randomly initialized
network and the answer is
yes and no actually you only need to
store the random c
to produce it so checkmate
um yeah they do so here they explain
this one-shot algorithm where they
simply look at the gradient of the
entropy
you can see with the maximum negative
gradient of
the entropy um they also have this
binary algorithm
if the task where they say if the task
is harder to differentiate
this kind of assumption of the convex
combination
thing does might not hold so what they
do is they have this
this binary algorithm where they do a
binary search
where so they they simply want to
circumvent
the necessity to evaluate
each of the masks by itself because that
takes long
so they do something in between where
they do this binary algorithm this is
right here
where they do this convex combination
they evaluate the gradient
but then they don't just take the the
highest
of the negative gradients they they
eliminate
half of them so you can see whenever
it's um lower than the median
they eliminate it and then they start
off with this new set of reduced alphas
so in each of these steps they eliminate
half of the masks and then they
recompute again
because because it is not a convex
problem
the the order might actually be
different in the second and third and
fourth
step of course this is simply
this is like halfway towards between
this one-shot algorithm and
trying each mask by itself um it's kind
of a
compromise i mean they they make it
they they really try to not not uh try
each mask
once because it's one of their
contributions right
but then they probably realized if we
just do it one shot sometimes it doesn't
work
uh so they go in between which is you
know it's a pretty cool idea
all right next experiments
we're now in this situation and you see
you see a number of things
so first of all we have a new we've
added a new baseline this psp
and you can see that the baselines
operate in this gg
regime so the baselines are given the
task during training
and given the task during evaluation
you see the upper bound here in gray is
where you train a model for each
task and you assume that's an upper
bound because you assume the tasks are
kind of unrelated
to each other which is is not the case
so there is actually potential to beat
the uh to beat the upper bound baseline
and subs up here you see operates in a
different regime
namely there's this regime of you're
given
the task during training but then during
testing you're
not given the task okay and this u here
it basically means that the labels you
assume that the labels of the tasks are
not
shared so in in this case
if you predict if you predict
like if you split mnist into always
that two class no if if you pre split
mnist into two tasks you predict
uh the first task is zero one two three
four the second task is five six seven
eight nine
okay and you have the same amount of
labels so you always have five output
neurons right
so you have one two three four five
output neurons
if you if the image here is like a five
that would be task task 1
label 0 right if your network
now predicts label 0 correctly
but predicts the the image to come from
task 1 you count it as a mistake
you say well you know you've predicted
the right output neuron but you've told
me it comes from task zero from
from the zero to four so i'm going to
count that as a
mistake so it really there isn't there
isn't a way for the network to
kind of go get around um
predicting the wrong tasks or kind of
share information so you assume
that the labels are not shared or
unshared
yeah so it's the sub sub here has
a significantly harder task than the
baselines keep
keep that in mind and now we're applying
our
because we we are not given the task
at inference time now we're applying our
heuristic
where we go and look at which of the
mask entropies is the lowest
respectively we use this actually this
one
shot algorithm where we look at the
gradients
and you can see this is on permuted
mnist
in permuted mnist what you do is you
take
mnist and you simply permute the pixels
and this it sounds crazy but you simply
permute the pixels
and that gives you a new task so you can
come up with like
almost an infinite number of tasks
because there are what 28 times 28
pixels so you can com
commute them 784 you know factorial
times which gives you like infinitely
many tasks
and so you can modulate so here you can
see the number of tasks learned
increases and at the beginning this
baseline
especially this line is doing fairly
well actually on par
with the upper bound when you only have
10 different tasks
however after that quickly degrades
however this subs up here it you know
keeps it keeps its performance which it
so this
doesn't only mean that it correctly
predicts the output neuron
it also correctly predicts which task
which permutation was applied to the
digit
simply by looking where the entropy is
high
right so that's pretty cool
and you know it's it's actually kind of
surprising
to be to be honest so on the left this
is a
lunette architecture and on the right
it's a a fully connected network now
the fully connected network here
performing better is
sort of expected first of all mnist is
really easy and can actually be solved
with a fully connected network and
second of all especially permuted amnest
i guess doesn't really conform to the
to the assumptions of convolutional
neural networks anymore again keep in
mind these tasks are very easy
um yeah so
um so especially for the fully connected
network of course each
permutation kind of looks the same
because
it's it doesn't care at the beginning
that
each pixels are next to each other
simply each pixel is a different
thing it's just the fact that it cannot
it cannot learn from one tasks much
about the other
tasks that's why you that's the nature
of permuted mnist
all right and then in this experiment
right here and this is the
sort of crown experiment they
learn they do this permuted mnist but
they go up to
2 500 tasks right
2 500 different permutations but
so but now they have an additional thing
right here
so again they have this sub sub where it
needs to predict
the correct permutation but also
they compare it with a an algorithm
that needs that is this n n right here
so in this nnn not not only are you not
given the task label
at testing time you are actually not
even given the task label at
training time but here the outputs are
shared so you know since since
you have no way of knowing which task it
is you've never given it
as long as you predict the correct uh
class
um you're good so it's always it's
always a 10 class classification problem
it's just
you know permuted you're not given
the task label here so first of all i
want to say
that this here the shared labels
it could actually contribute to the
success of this algorithm right here
because
even though you permute the pixels um
you can still sort of do things like
count the frequency
of of light pixels versus dark pixels in
mnist and that
might already give you a very very big
hint
right or you know simple correlation
of of two pixels though that's that's a
task specific thing but
the the frequency of light pixels versus
dark pixels will already give you
a big um boost in accuracy and
now you can actually share that feature
that feature will always be the same for
every permutation so this is something
you can share between tasks
and i would like so one way
i guess you could eliminate that well i
don't know
i'm not sure is you kind of have to
randomize the number of light pixels but
keep the classes the same
yeah it's going to be complicated right
but just keep that in mind however how
how does the algorithm even decide so
they have a heuristic right here as well
namely
they say okay if
we don't have no task identity during
training or inference
where task identity is entirely unknown
even during training if sub sub is
uncertain about the current task
identity it is likely that the data does
not do not belong to any task seen so
far
when this occurs a new super mask is
allocated
and the number of tasks learned so far
is incremented
okay so the they go with the same
principle right here they say if we get
a new training sample
we just evaluated against all the masks
that we had so far
or we do our you know one-shot algorithm
to to approximate which masks
gets us a low entropy if none of the
mask
gets us a low entropy then we decide
this must be some kind of unseen task so
we're going to allocate a new
mask for this unseen tasks
and that heuristic as you can see
it performs fairly fairly well where was
our graph
our graph was down here in fact it
performs pretty much
on par with where you know the task
during
training and just not during
during inference up until like here the
very
last bit if you really get into the high
task regime
where i guess it starts getting it
starts getting confusing so this
this heuristic might start to break down
but it might just be a fact
how they tune their constants like they
have to define a threshold where they
say okay if the entropy
is somehow higher than this threshold
then we allocate a new
a new task and this might be optimized
in order to solve this again these tasks
are very very very
very easy so keep keep that in mind
um yeah okay so this
basically was the experimental part
of that paper now they consider
different extensions
uh to that and i'm not sure oh they also
consider
some ablations which are pretty
interesting
so here they say we are going to
up the kind of the hardness of the task
with with rotated mnist and also their
model
does pretty well on the rotated mnist
task where
the differences uh of between the
the differences between the tasks are
simply some of them are rotated by 10
degrees so that's a tiny rotation
in the indy right if you have a
number three you kind of rotate it by
ten i can't even draw that subtle of a
rotation
by 10 degrees and um
you know the sub sub must correctly
predict
which task the image is from
or it will not get the it will not get a
correct
uh reward and the fact that it performs
pretty well
and the fact that it has you know
rotation degrees where it
outperforms the baseline that is all
actually given
the rotation so it's given the task at
inference time
is pretty pretty remarkable again
i i believe this is due to the fact that
these tasks are so easy and therefore
these entropy it just
spikes um when you get the correct
thing because it it sort of it sort of
latches onto very easy features for each
task
so i'm going to guess that the tasks are
you know generally solvable by maybe
correlating two pixels right if like
this pixel
correlates with this pixel if the
correlation is high it's a three
if the correlation is low it's something
else okay and then
if you rotate it it's just not the case
anymore that this pixel and this pixel
the correlation is very high so
um if you predict using this correlation
you'll get a pretty low confidence and
i'm going to guess that yeah if you have
discrete tasks and it's in this task
then your confidence will just
spike because the task is so easy and
because all the tasks are
about equally hurt because if you can
find this correlation here
you can find it over here it's simply
going to be two different
two different pixels in this task and
then
one as you try the masks whenever you
hit the one where you can predict pretty
confidently
with those two pixels then your
your confidence is going to spike your
entropy is going to get down
and you know it's that task right
uh they also uh here they compare
um where is it the one-shot algorithm
so they they they use their one-shot
algorithm
to and and they put it on a baseline so
this baseline
where they always actually have to give
it the
the task um they augment it
by by their their one-shot algorithm to
select
the task and it turns out they can you
know
make it perform fairly well not on par
with them
interestingly but they can make it
perform also fairly well actually better
than it was performing before
so they have different extensions right
here
and that's some of them are pretty
important the one
important thing they do is they have
these superfluous
neurons and that's sort of hidden and
it's
always a bit um so here
for example you see in the output they
say we have a
lynette model using output size 500.
now there are only 10 different labels
in the mnist task right also in the
permuted mns test there are
10 different labels i mean there are a
total of
25 000 labels if you have 2500 tasks
but the neural network has output size
10.
however their neural network here has
output size
500 which is surprising
so they say right here and
we're going to get to the hopfield
network at the very end
for those who are still around because
that's i think that should be its own
paper but
you know um they say
it could use an output of size l where l
is the actual
number of labels per per task
though we find in practice that it helps
significantly to add
extra neurons to the final layer
specifically
we consider outputs p in r
s so s is higher than l
and refer to the neurons that are passed
as superfluous neurons
so let's try to make
sense of this so they have a neural
network
and let's say it's a three class
classification task
right so you have three classes and
that's what you would do
they simply add a bunch of neurons right
here that means they also they you know
they add all of the connections from the
previous layer to those neurons
but still the classes can only be either
0 1 or 2. these classes never appear
during training so they claim
this helps during during their procedure
and i i thought about it a bit
and we might be able to try to
guess why it makes sense they say they
simply say we observe
that helps and i mean you know
let's let's try to make sense of it okay
so
if we train if we train our model
using these too many neurons what
happens well our label is always going
to be of the top
three neurons so let's say our label is
one this is going to result in a one hot
vector like this now what are we
training
in this layer here in this layer here
we're training logits
okay so pre pre soft max outputs
so our our algorithm
our cross entropy loss is going to
push all of these here down
during every single training point it's
going to push this one up
and all of these down now these three
here are going to be pushed
up and down depending on the label
however
all of these down here are going to be
only pushed
down during the entire training so they
are going to be
exceptionally low numbers
okay now if we then come
and we look at the at the entropy
of this the the entropy
i i think honestly this is simply you
could
achieve the same thing by using a
different
temperature parameter in the soft max or
in the entropy that you consider
because why can this help and this helps
with inferring which task it's coming
from right
so if you consider a task where you only
have
three outputs so you don't have this bit
down here
and you look at the entropy um it's
going to be
you know it's going to be something um
something sorry i have to draw this
right here it's going to be
like this anyway it's fairly confident
but if
and maybe for the other tasks it's not
going to be
as confident you know it's maybe going
to be like this a bit
however if you have those and if it's of
the correct tasks i'm going to guess
this kind of stays the same because
they're really low but if it's of the
incorrect tasks
then you're not sure and you not being
sure
about the output also means that you
allocate a lot more
to these things right here because
you've sort of never seen
this particular kind of training
examples so you're not sure so you're
just going to distribute
your kind of uh your probability mass
across these
things right here because you've not
been trained
on that kind of input right it's very
important to see that
this is task this is the correct task
which they always label j
and for for any other incorrect task
you've never seen
data like this so these things here
sort of act like an outlier class
without you
explicitly training an outlier class you
simply train these things
during training you make them small but
you
it's important to notice you always make
them small
from a data point that comes from their
particular task
okay that's what you train them for
and now if you input a data point from a
different task
they have less reason to be
small because this is an outlier data
point
so you have much more fluctuations so
you have more fluctuations here and
therefore
the entropy is going to be even higher
all right this is sort of how i make
sense of the fact that these additional
superfluous neurons
help here they act as kind of an outlier
detector
for the training data set of that
particular task
now because you know you have different
training data for each task
they go further and they say it actually
works
even better it works even better if we
instead of this entropy heuristic we
consider another heuristic
accordingly we consider an objective g
which encourages the s neurons to have
large negative values and computes as
an alternative to entropy in equation
four
so g they analyze down in the appendix
and we're just quickly going to look
at what g is sorry this is about to load
right here and it's very
interesting to see what g is
or is it yes so g
is going to be this right here
so y are the logits and then g
is this expression right here so
and in fact it's this expression with
the with a bit of a modification
so it's going to be g is going to be the
log
sum x of the logits
right so it's
this is some this is somewhat like the
entropy
and what we're going to consider is the
gradient of g so what we want is the
gradient of g
with respect to our alphas
and the condition here with this detach
operation
is that
the gradient of g should be
you know the gradient of the loss
function for all
v that are superfluous neurons and
zero otherwise so we're going to
detach the gradient of g
for all the real neurons for all the the
actual
logits of the output class and we're
only going to consider the gradient
flowing through the superfluous neurons
so
all of this here is if we take the
gradient it's only going to
flow to in these in the last layer
through the gradients of these
superfluous neurons
okay and that's why we don't need the
entropy
because the entropy always considers you
know the difference
sort of the difference between the
correct label and the other labels
we are pretty sure that in our
superfluous neurons we don't have the
correct label
okay so this log the log sum
x of our of these outputs here
what will they represent well this is
sort of a flatness measure again
it's kind of like the entropy except we
don't have a correct
label right here if one of them
is very high and the other ones are very
lower if they're generally
very high up
then this will be high however
consider the difference between this
and this where they're all super small
and also they're all pretty equal the
log sum
x will be very small so this is an
alternative
where we can basically only look at
these superfluous neurons and say
is are these superfluous neurons all
very small
and you know none of them basically says
i'm the correct label then we can be
pretty sure
that over here there is some
confidence however if they are sort of
kind of
larger and you know generally kind of uh
generally large maybe unequal that means
we are not very confident because
these are our outlier classes they
shouldn't be they shouldn't be large at
all
so an alternative to looking at the
entropy of this distribution is to build
such superfluous neurons
and then look at those and only those
and so the gradient of only those in
order to decide which task it's from
it's an interesting idea i have to say
but i've
maybe one could achieve sort of the same
thing
with a with a temperature parameter here
or by
building an explicit outlier detection
um but it's generally an interesting
idea for outlier detection i have to say
i've never really seen anything like
this though i also haven't
really considered it so here they show
the
importance and you've seen in the
experiments before that there sometimes
was this
h objective and also this g objective
so you can light a look at the entropy
but also you can look at the g
in both cases you have superfluous
neurons so before you actually saw you
have
500 neurons for a task of
um for a task of 10 that needed
10 output classes right so this tells me
that these superfluous neurons are
pretty important for them
and um it
this is probably one of the things that
makes
this work right these superfluous
neurons so
you're kind of setting up a trap where
for the wrong models you let it run into
this trap
of assigning a lot of weight into these
outlier classes and only if the correct
model is trained to not do that
on the particular data that you're
considering
i don't think this comes through in the
paper too much that this is one of i
guess this is one of the main factors
making this work and you can see
right here they actually do an
experiment so i don't want to be too
mean
where they say look if we train with
just
25 classes and this is permuted mnist
so the necessary amount would be 10.
so if we train with only 25 you can see
how quickly
we degrade right here however as we go
up and train with a hundred
and two hundred we get better and better
in fact if we train with this g
objective
it always sort of outperforms the h
interestingly the more output neurons
you have the less this difference seems
to be but maybe the
percent difference is the same
the percent error difference differences
the same i don't know i can't tell from
here
yeah so this isn't all
there is also this hop field network
going on where they say okay okay
so essentially we're actually training
different models right we're not
really superimposing all of these models
we're training a different mask for each
of the tasks and
kind of remembering the masks and so on
can we
also build a model where we actually
only have
one model and that's what they do right
here
where they build a hot field network
which is basically just a a big matrix
this is the hopfield network and then
they encode
the masks in this hopfield network so
specifically the hopfield network is of
size d squared
where it is able to encode
two to the d different um binary strings
and it does so in a fuzzy way but you
know you can prove that if you construct
the hopfield network like this
where z is a binary string you can
recover
the binary strings by gradient descent
in the
hopfield network and
as obviously the more binary strings you
encode
the less you get out like it's not magic
you can't store
that many bits into the thing that
doesn't have that many bits
but um i believe you know
again this is using gradient descent and
it can do so with surprising
um it was surprising accuracy so
remember that these here are bits
while these here are floating point
numbers so
the comparison that i just made isn't
entirely fair
uh but i don't i don't want to go into
the hopfield networks because i really
feel this should be
its own paper i guess they just want to
show that it's it's also possible
uh to compress these masks into
one into one thing such that
i can't make the argument anymore that
hey all you're doing is training
different models for different tasks
all right all in all pretty cool paper
as i said pretty dense paper
i invite you to read it they have a big
appendix where they have more
experiments and so on
and explain everything in detail all in
all
i from this i don't really take the
method but the ideas are very
interesting
and i am enjoying excited to see where
this goes in the future
all right i'll see you next time bye